Attorney General William bar will
release a redacted version of Robert
Muller's report on Russian election
interference in just a few hours but
first he plans to hold a news conference
to discuss what's in it now Democrats in
Congress object they demand that bar
cancelled this news conference because
they believe it appears it's designed to
shape public perceptions of the report
before anybody can read it and this
morning Democratic House Speaker Nancy
Pelosi and Senate Minority Leader Chuck
Schumer are calling on robert muller to
publicly testify the public version of
the special counsels report will have
some information removed as required by
law a CBS News poll taken last month
shows a majority of Americans across
party lines want the full report not
redacted report but the full report
released Paula Reed has covered them all
our investigation since it began and she
is at the Justice Department Paula good
morning good morning Jon Attorney
General William Barr vowed to be as
transparent as possible with the balla
report but in a short time he'll hold a
press conference to discuss a document
no one's seen a senior administration
official tell CBS News Barr wanted to
hold this event to discuss the process
that he went through to redact Muller's
findings but Democrats are accusing the
Attorney General of trying to protect
President Trump and they are demanding
that the full report be released to the
public the Attorney General appears to
be waging a media campaign on behalf of
President Trump House Judiciary Chairman
Jerry Nadler last night accused Attorney
General William bar of helping president
Trump prepare a rebuttal response to the
Muller report he has briefed the White
House on the report before providing
Congress a copy Barr has not been
willing to publicly discuss any
conversations between the Justice
Department and the White House ahead of
this release I'm landing the plane right
now I'm just not going to get into the
details of the process until the planes
on the ground lawmakers will be
receiving the report 27 days after
Special Counsel Robert Muller delivered
it to the Attorney General
Muller's nearly four hundred page report
was the culmination of 22 months of work
including more than 2,800 subpoenas
nearly 500 search warrants and
approximately 500 witness interviews two
days
to receiving the report bar summarized
Muller's work in a four-page memo
stating the special counsel found no
evidence of collusion and bar concluded
there wasn't enough evidence to
establish that the president committed
obstruction of justice
terney general bar is not allowing the
facts of the Moller report to speak for
themselves but it's trying to bake in
the narrative about the report to the
benefit of the White House bar has said
he will redact grand jury material
evidence related to ongoing
investigations classified information
and details about anyone not criminally
charged in an interview Wednesday
President Trump praised his Attorney
General and said he was not at all
worried he's been a fantastic Attorney
General he's grabbed it by the horns
issued never happened to a president or
to this country again what took place
and you'll see a lot of very strong
things come out President Trump said he
may even hold a press conference after
the report is released now here's what
we know about how it will be delivered
lawmakers on the hill will be the first
to receive the redacted report and they
will get it on compact discs as CBS News
has confirmed that Hill staffers were
prepared for this and they checked and
they still have computers with cd-rom
drives but it's unclear whether or not
they have enough color printers to
support hundreds of pages of color-coded
redactions once lawmakers receive the
report it will be released to the public
through a link on the special
counsellors website Norah I can tell you
Paula
I do not have a computer anymore with
the cd-rom thank you so much excellent
reporting